I've searched for you Rick WTM-72!
Such a fool you are to kidnap Shogun Morty, the soul to us Ninja Rick.
That Morty is not a Morty that you nitwits can just make off with.
Hand him over and we will let you have an easy death-
Welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
going to be my new Rick and Morty season
four bonus episode breakdown some of you
may have been confused when you saw this
what's going on is this supposed to be
from Rick and Morty season four episode
six
is this another April Fool's Day prank
episode there's a whole bunch of Easter
eggs for a lot of anime series including
Naruto when he goes full Rinnegan and
some really classic samurai films from
the lone wolf and cub series so we'll
break it all down there's a new round of
that Rick and Morty giveaway - all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite moment from this
short episode on the video the story of
where this short episode came from is
actually pretty fascinating tube because
you'll notice the studio dean is all
over the credits there are Japanese
animes studio if you don't watch a lot
of anime Jason DeMarco who's one of the
programmers at Adult Swim in the
co-creator of Toonami said that they had
been working on this with Studio Dean
for the past year so it took them a year
to make this five-minute short episode
so it's sort of their April Fool's Day
Rick and Morty episode 4 - Nami
they dropped it in the middle of a sword
art online - Nami episode with no
warning at all it just appeared in the
middle of the episode so a lot of people
were instantly confused not recognizing
the lone wolf and cub references
thinking that it was actually meant to
be an integration with sword art online
the lead producer on it Maki terashima
is actually known for working on a lot
of projects like fooly cooly progressive
fully Cooley alternative he's working on
the upcoming news imake anime which
everyone is really excited about and I
saw in my timeline that some of you also
correctly noticed that the people that
were doing the voices for this are the
official Japanese voiceover artists for
regular Rick and Morty episodes so if
you watched Rick and Morty in Japan this
is the version of Rick that you would
hear he even does the burps during this
too.
Such a fool you are to kidnap Shogun Morty, the soul to us Ninja Rick.
So even though this is happening in an alternate reality,
he says Rick WTM 72 it's still very
similar to what you would see c-137 Rick
doing which next big Easter egg we can
say this probably happening somewhere in
the central finite curve because the
further out you get from the central
finite curve the more differences you
start to see in Rick's and Morty's until
they become unrecognizable the reason
why he's called WTM 72 Rick is because
1972 is when the first two lone wolf and
cub samurai films came out those were
lone wolf and cub sword of vengeance and
then lone wolf and cub a baby cart at
the river Styx if you haven't seen any
of those they're classics I would
definitely recommend checking them out
they've also done a manga series for it
they've also done an anime series for it
so there is a ton of lone wolf and cub
out there for you to check out in fact
it was so popular back in the 70s and so
influential that it's been referenced
and ripped off by hundreds of other
movies and TV shows since then more
recently I've been doing videos for Star
Wars the Mandalorian series on Disney
plus they actually did a direct
reference to lone wolf and cub during
the Mandalorian episode - just a couple
months ago so lone wolf and cub shows up
all over the place even in the Star Wars
universe but the plot of the Rick and
Morty short episode basically plays out
a little bit like the plot of the lone
wolf and cub films the main character
referenced by Rick WT m-72 here is Ogami
ito
he's the executioner of the most
powerful Shogun so he's responsible for
going around to a bunch of a lesser
clans and enforcing the Shogun's rules
eventually he and his wife have a baby
that he names die Goro which is the cub
character in this play by the Morty that
you see here in the little cart
one day he returns home to find his
entire family except for his baby's son
has been murdered by a rival clan the
rival clan is trying to usurp the local
power structure so because ito or
Samurai Ric in this case is a very
powerful figure in that power structure
they try to frame him for wrongly
wanting to kill his Shogun so the title
of this short episode is Samurai and
Shogun and Rick and Morty all these
other Rick's that are coming for him are
the Shogun's men but when they all
portal in and say how dare you try to
steal this Morty he's our soul that's
the Rick and Morty people with Studio
Dean going a little off-book just
referencing a lot of other
anime tropes so it's not a literal copy
and paste from the plot of lone wolf and
cub there's just a lot of lone wolf and
cub stuff happening during this when all
the samurai blades come out of Morty's
cart and start taking out all the other
assassins that's a reference to this
scene from lone wolf and cub when Ito is
telling his son you can choose the ball
you can choose to play and have fun and
be a normal little kid or you can choose
the way of the sword and I will teach
you to be a samurai and seek revenge for
your mother's death it's super hardcore
in the film because he tells his son if
you want to choose the ball then I will
send you to live with your mother
but remember his mother has just been
killed so he's basically telling his son
if you don't choose to become a samurai
and seek revenge for her death you're
also going to die too
most of the kills that he performs
during this when he's taking out all the
Shogun's assassins are just referenced
in the visual style of lone wolf and cub
traditional Japanese samurai films with
the way the blood sprays out after he
decapitate them when it gets super
trippy and he starts having all the
visions that's when they start to do the
Naruto references he gets the Rinnegan I
don't really consider myself an expert
on the Naruto anime or the manga but
when he gets gassed and has all these
crazy visions and then comes out of it
and takes down these other assassins
those are again jutsu and Rinnegan
references if you're not a big Naruto
fan or you're not a big fan of Japanese
anime genjutsu it's just another class
of like a rogue class like ninjutsu
genjutsu is just another one of those a
lot of their fighting ability is based
around being able to create illusions
forcing people to see things that aren't
really there
so the Naruto genjutsu rick's force
samurai rick to see all these crazy
visions it seems like he goes on this
crazy mind space trip but then it gets
the Rinnegan it comes out of it and
takes them down so Rinnegan is this
really powerful ability that people have
within Naruto it translates to some
saara I some Sora being the eastern
philosophy concept for the cycle of
death and rebirth samsara isn't
originally a Japanese or Naruto
exclusive concept it's a broader Eastern
concept with roots and Hinduism and
Buddhism within the Naruto series the
Rinnegan is said to be this crazy
godlike power that's said to be passed
down from the heavens during times of
disorder in the person who gains it
becomes this god of creation or
potential god of destruction one of the
abilities the Rinnegan grants to
different users is the ability to see
through illusions so
that's how this version of samurai Rick
is able to see through these genjutsu
Rick's illusions and then get out of it
the Rinnegan ability goes way beyond
that but like I said this short Rick and
Morty episode is mostly meant to be a
lone wolf and cub reference so just very
light Naruto and other anime references
a lot of you also asking what's going on
with the rest of the season four
episodes when is Rick and Morty Season
four Episode six through ten going to
air before - the big virus outbreak at
Hollywood was forced to shut down and
just hit the pause button on all movies
and television shows my assumption was
is that they would start premiering the
rest of the episodes during this summer
the good news in all this though is the
lot of animation can actually be worked
on from people's homes so a lot of
animated series are still in production
even though most live-action series have
paused completely the only thing that
they really can't do right now is do
more voiceover recording with the actors
so they can't do a lot of retakes which
sometimes can cause problems for
episodes so worst case scenario they
probably just released the rest of the
Rick and Morty episodes at the end of
this year around November just like they
did the first half in 2019 or if they
get them done a little bit faster maybe
they'll be able to drop them all by the
end of the summer it's a really bad
situation for the world right now so if
you wondered why a lot of TV shows have
gone on break and aren't airing new
episodes that's mostly why but if you
spotted any other big anime references
during the Rick and Morty samurai
episode just write them below in the
comments and I'll name a giveaway winner
the next time I post a Rick and Morty
bonus video everyone click here for my
Rick and Morty season 4 episode 6
trailer video in Easter eggs and click
here for that brand new Marvel Iron Man
announcement thank you so much for
watching everyone stays safe.
I'll see you guys tonight!